breakfast time fruit and vegetables for
a power smoothie to get him through the
day yawn boy duck no longer eats meat
fish or dairy products when he turned
vegan he changed his whole life he left
his job as a top manager at a big car
company and he left his family from the
outside I led a comfortable middle-class
life I had a good salary a little house
and pretty much everything I went on
holiday three times a year there was
nothing missing from the outside but
inside there was a lot of emptiness so
he swapped his suit for a sweatshirt and
embarked on a new life with a new woman
and a startup to promote the vegan
lifestyle with the help of investors he
opened his first supermarket in Berlin
two years ago there are some 6,000 vegan
products on sale 60% more than in other
organic shops and there are also
convenience products and 77 types of
cheese
via coconut we look for suppliers from
all over the world small innovative
companies who have the same values as we
do who are interested in sustainability
who are vegan and don't do anybody any
harm who makes sure their employees are
paid fairly that trade is fair and that
everything is well balanced most of the
shops employees are also vegan all 26
get a commission if profits are good
do you often VT taco some sexism
depending on the daily turnover if we've
reached the goals and sold a lot then we
get a bonus on our account and how much
does that make this could add up to a
hundred euros a month
generally wages are not extremely high
but Braddock doesn't pay himself a big
salary either he earns 2,000 euros a
month
his six-figure salary is history but his
experience comes in very handy today
I often draw parallels especially when
it comes to talking with investors or
banks you can feed on your experience
definitely presenting projects preparing
figures setting focuses writing business
plans that was all part of my activity
before part of the daily agenda the
supermarket has an annual turnover of
1.6 million euros with some 400
customers a day four times as much as he
had expected
there are already two vagin supermarkets
in Berlin and Breda has just opened a
third one in Frankfurt he says it wasn't
difficult to find investors we're
opening 20 branches in the next three
years very ambitious and all over Europe
not only in Germany there's similar
pressures before but it's positive Radek
has already drawn some criticism from
purist vegans for wanting to expand so
much but he's not too fussed about this
he's pretty sure his work/life balance
will be better this time around